Uh, let's see.
Let's go next to, uh, let's go to our caller
from the six oh five area code.
Who's calling today from six oh five.
All right.
Hi David.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Who's this?
Okay.
This is Daniel from South Dakota.
Hey Daniel, what's going on?
So I support a living, you know, $15 an hour
wage, but some people like Andrew Yang has
been speaking a lot about automation recently.
And so I feel that like a legitimate concern
that some people have about a living wage
is that in order to save money, companies
can just automate away some of their jobs.
Uh, and you know, they'll continue to make
a profit because of that.
And that's already been happening like in
Fast Food I've noticed, uh, with automated
kiosks and stuff, she's, the question is,
is acceleration of automation, is that like
a legitimate concern at all when it comes
to a living wage?
And if so was ubi and effective way to counter
that?
So listen, I mean here, so the, the answer
is yes, automation is a concern when we think
about living wages, but it's not one that
is particularly exacerbated by the winimum
wage being $15 versus 13.
And you know a lot of people like to point
to the fast food kiosks as you talk about
because after minimum wages were increased
in certain places, you saw fast food locations
there deploy these kiosks.
Those kiosks have been in development for
a very long time.
It doesn't just happen overnight that the
minimum wage goes up and then all of a sudden
these kiosks show up.
So the truth is that those companies had been
planning on doing that for a very long time.
And so I, if your argument, and it sounds
like at least part of your argument is that
a $15 minimum wage is not going to solve the
problem of technological automation.
I agree with you, and this is one of the big
sort of missing elements that I'm glad Andrew
Yang is talking about it and many, many other
elected officials are not.
It's that whether the minimum wage is 1315
or 17 number one in lots of places that's
not a living wage or it's barely a living
wage.
That's a real issue.
And number two, the issue of automation as
well as machine learning and artificial intelligence
is going to make a lot of that minimum wage
discussion, not obsolete, but it's going to
make it less applicable to a lot of jobs.
So I'm completely with you.
It's not being discussed in a serious manner.
So would you support having both the ubi and
a living wage?
Yeah.
Listen, I'm in support of all of those things.
And for people who criticize just a $15 minimum
wage as being merely a bandaid on our economic
system, I agree, right?
There's a bigger problem that had bandaids
not going to fix ubi of $1,000 no matter.
You know, I disagreed with Andrew Yang's initial
version, which was the thousand replaces other
benefits.
I think it should be additive, but that disagreement
aside, that stuff only is on the fringes of
the broader economic problems, or I guess
I would call them deeper economic problems
that we have to solve.
All right.
Thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.
Thank you very much.
Great.
Uh, great to hear from you